you've probably heard of quantum
computers
but what about the quantum internet
researchers think that a quantum
internet could be one of the most
exciting developments in quantum
technology
and now they may be one step closer
using a device called a quantum repeater
[Music]
so what is a quantum repeater how does
it work
and what might this mean for the future
of quantum tech
first some background classical
computers
work using bits units of information
that can either be
1 or 0 on or off up or down
not much use on their own but put enough
of them together
and you can start computing the more you
have
the more complex the task you can
achieve
quantum computers use a different kind
of bit
qubits qubits can read up or down too
but they can also be a mix of both at
the same time
a superposition of the two states
this can increase the speed of some
computations exponentially
but that's not the only thing that makes
qubits special
they can also become entangled a quantum
property
that keeps two qubits in a shared state
if you measure the state of 1 you will
know the state of the other
and this works no matter how far apart
they are
in theory you could entangle qubits
across a room
a country even a globe
and that is how scientists hope to
unlock the quantum
internet so where does the quantum
repeater
come in well the goal of a quantum
repeater is to help
establish entanglement between distant
cubits
and they do this using photons
entangling two qubits that are close
together
is relatively simple qubits and photons
get entangled easily
and if you take two photons that are
entangled with two qubits
and measure them together the cubits
become entangled
even though they never came into contact
photons can travel down fiber optic
cables
that allows you to entangle qubits that
are up to a few tens of kilometers apart
but move the cubits too far apart and
the photons can get lost
the likelihood of your qubits becoming
entangled
decreases the further apart they are
what you need is a relay station enter
the quantum repeater the quantum
repeater works using the same principle
essentially it's a simple quantum
computer with specialized qubits
whose only job is to relay entanglement
first a qubit is entangled with the
quantum repeater just as before
but the quantum repeaters qubits have
the special ability to hold on to that
entanglement
giving a second qubit somewhere else in
the world
time to get entangled as well and if two
qubits are entangled with the quantum
repeater
they can also become entangled with each
other
in theory if you want to entangle qubits
over even longer
distances you can just use more quantum
repeaters
to form a chain you could even entangle
a network of quantum repeaters in
advance
ready for when you need to connect two
qubits in different places
what you're left with is a quantum
internet
but why go through all that trouble well
a network of entangled qubits lets you
do a whole range of things
you could teleport quantum information
between qubits
or you can use them for super secure
communication
researchers could connect tools like
telescopes
or build ultra precise quantum clocks
you could also build bigger and more
powerful quantum computers
by linking up distributed networks of
qubits
quantum repeaters could change the game
but they are not the only way to
entangle qubits over long distances
if you do away with fiber optic cables
and instead use highly sophisticated
lasers
in theory you could entangle qubits over
thousands of kilometers
researchers in china have trialled this
approach using laser equipped satellites
they broke all records by linking
quantum devices
1200 kilometers apart
in the future we could imagine a
combination of systems
a network of quantum repeaters could
connect a country
and satellites could connect the world
either way creating a robust system to
allow qubits to talk to each other is
vital
if the quantum internet is to fulfill
its potential
and quantum repeaters could be the first
link in the chain